-Welcome back to the show.
I always love having you on.
-Thanks, honey.
-Last time you were on,
it was right before
you won the Oscar for
"The Eyes of Tammy Faye."
-Can you believe it?!
-Yes!
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Touchdown!
-You won the Oscar!
I mean, touchdown!
Oh, my gosh!
You actually posted this.
"Did this actually happen
two weeks ago?
Asking for a friend."
With you holding --
I mean, congratulations.
-Thanks, man.
-You were unbelievable in that.
And I called it
when we were talking.
I was like, "Oh, my gosh.
It was so amazing."
So I think I --
-I was shocked. I really was.
-Really?
-Yeah, I was completely not
expecting it at all.
-The more people told me it
was going to happen, I was like,
"It's not, but thank you
for being so nice to me."
-I mean, it's just
when you get that hyped up,
but you're down to like,
you know,
whatever -- however
many nominees are in there,
it's like you just get nervous.
You're like, "One of us
is going to go home with it."
But you crushed it.
It was so good
and well-deserved.
Congrats on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was so happy for you.
And now, recently, you made this
announcement yesterday.
You're going back to Broadway.
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
-Are you excited?
-I'm so excited.
I'm going to play Nora in
"A Doll's House."
-Wow!
-Jamie Lloyd is directing.
Amy Herzog did the adaptation.
And, yeah, it's, you know,
just an iconic theater role,
so no pressure.
-Yeah. You're like,
"Why do I do this to myself?"
-Yeah.
-Do you like doing live theater?
-Oh, yes and no.
I mean, the last time I did it
was like a decade ago.
The great thing about live
theater is anything can happen.
And I think that's part of the
feeling with the audience, too.
When I go to live theater,
I'm like, "Ooh, there's a pause.
Did someone forget their lines?"
It's, like, this exciting thing.
-Yeah.
-And the last time I did it,
it was just me and my dog.
And my dog, Chaplin,
has three legs.
So when he walks, he, like,
makes this hopping sound
because of his tags.
It's like,
"Jing-a-jing-a-jing-a-jing."
-Yeah.
-And I was onstage, performing,
and there's a note
on my dressing-room door,
"Please don't open the door."
-Oh, no.
-And it's a very serious scene.
And, all of a sudden, I hear,
"Jing-a-jing-a-jing-a-jing."
And I'm on the stage --
Like, David Strathairn and I
are having
a very dramatic moment.
And then it's,
"Jing-a-jing-a-jing-a-jing."
And then it stops.
And the audience kind of goes...
[ Gasps ]
And I thought, "Yep, he's right
next to me right now."
So I just -- I looked at David
and I started saying a line
and then I walked offstage.
And then Chaplin was like,
"Jing-a-jing-a-jing-a-jing."
Following me.
-Made his debut, Broadway debut.
-Picked him up.
I took him back out
for curtain call.
-Oh, did you really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's a good mom.
Come on, yeah.
Are you going to bring --
-Oh, no.
-No.
-His rights have been revoked.
Yeah.
-But this is gonna be
exciting -- back on Broadway.
-I'm excited.
-I also wanted to ask you
a couple more things.
Recently,
I saw you brought up --
You were doing an interview
and you said
you and Anne Hathaway
thought of remaking
"Death Becomes Her,"
which originally starred
Meryl Streep, Goldie Hawn,
And I go, "Ooh,
that's kind of a good idea."
-Yeah, well, this interview
was many months ago,
and I was shooting with Annie.
And the interviewer said,
"You know, is there a remake
that you would like to do?"
And I was like,
"Well, I don't know."
And, well, funny enough,
Annie and I were on set,
and we said, "That would be
a great movie to do.
That would be so much fun."
And I said this
to the interviewer,
and then, of course, all of a
sudden, it's everywhere.
"They're going to remake
'Death Becomes Her.'"
-Yeah.
-But, I mean, I don't think
you can remake that movie --
unless you swap the genders.
So it's two men drinking
the magic potion
to try to, like,
stay young and sexy forever,
and they're fighting over
the love of a woman.
-That's the take. Yes.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I love that.
-Alright, so, it might --
-Send in your tape.
-I'm going to send in my tape.
You're going to love my acting.
It's so good.
There was also a rumor
I heard that
you would like to play
a Bond villain.
-Well, yeah, when I started in
the industry about 10 years ago,
everyone kept asking me, "Would
you like to be a Bond Girl?"
Because it was -- For a woman
in the industry, it was like,
ooh, the pinnacle of success
to play a Bond Girl.
And for me, I was like,
"No, I want to be the villain."
Like, I love this idea of, like,
Bond being afraid of me.
That, like -- I love that.
-Yeah.
-And, so, yeah, of course,
anyone wants to call me
with a Bond-villain role,
I'm there.
-Yeah. They're actually looking
for a new James Bond.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, talking about
switching the roles.
You could be the
first female James Bond.
-No. No interest at all.
-What?!
-No, no.
-Why not?
-I might be the only person
who's ever said
they have no interest in
playing James Bond.
-You don't want the...
[ Vocalizes
"The James Bond" theme ]
-No. No interest.
-What?!
-I want to torture James Bond!
-Okay. Alright, you can
torture James Bond.
-Let me have my dream, Jimmy!
-Yes, I don't want to get in
the way of your dreams ever.
I want to talk about
"George & Tammy,"
because I believe the last time
I interviewed you,
you were in your makeup chair
doing this.
-Yes, we were on Zoom.
-Yes.
I appreciate it you doing that.
-Of course.
George Jones, Tammy Wynette --
two legends,
country-music legends.
-I know. Again, no pressure.
-Yeah, I know.
Why do you do this to yourself?
-Because I'm a masochist.
-But, I mean, how do you get
involved in this role?
Do you -- I know you sing,
but do you get intimidated
when you --
-I mean, I like to say I can
tell a story through song.
I never really thought of myself
as a singer.
I sing in "Tammy Faye,"
but that's also, like,
singing up to Jesus,
and so there was, like,
a sense of camp to it that --
Tammy Wynette hasn't --
I mean, she's serious.
You know, it's very serious
when she --
-But you sound fantastic.
-Oh, geez.
Thanks for saying that.
-I'm sorry to make you --
I'm sorry.
I don't want to embarrass you.
But I have to talk about this.
-I mean, all I really knew
about her was
she sang the song
"Stand By Your Man."
But, you know, there was a lot
of controversy about that song.
And, you know,
she kept saying that song
doesn't mean women
are a doormat.
And, in reality,
she married five times.
So the song should have been
like "Stand By Your Men."
-She had a lot, yeah.
Here's pic of you and
Michael Shannon as
George and Tammy.
How is Michael Shannon?
-Oh, great.
-He's a friend of the show.
-I know.
I think I've seen him in a cape
on this show or something once.
-Yeah, he was dressed as, like,
Alvin and the Chipmunks once.
He just came out -- He's just a
fun, fun human being.
I love that guy.
-I know.
We worked together 11 years ago
on a movie called
"Take Shelter."
-Oh, yeah.
-And so we've been
friends since.
And he's a musician.
I'd gone to see his band,
Corporal, play.
And so I knew
he would be great for this.
-Yeah, and he can sing. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-It's fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jessica Chastain and
Michael Shannon in
"George & Tammy."
Take a look at this.
-Our first time.
[ Click ]
♪♪
-♪ Take me ♪
♪ Take me to your darkest room ♪
♪ Close every window
and bolt every door ♪
♪ The very first moment ♪
♪ I heard your voice ♪
♪ I'd be in darkness no more ♪
-Oh, my gosh! Come on!
Jessica Chastain!
What more do you want?
"George & Tammy" premieres
December 4th at 9:00 p.m.
on Showtime.
We'll be right back with
Martha Stewart.
Stick around, everybody.